If a vegan falls in the forest ...
(Laughter)
And no one's there
to hear them say, "I'm vegan!"
(Laughter)
Are they even really vegan?
(Laughter and applause)
I like to preface conversations
about my dietary habits with jokes
because brains love the ha-has
and because sometimes you say
the word "vegan"
and people get a little afraid.
Their mind immediately conjures
this nonexistent super vegan
who's an amalgam of every annoying thing
they've ever heard a vegan say.
(Laughter)
And at that point, they're checked out.
Now if you've managed
to somehow avoid the zeitgeist
for the last 15 or 20 years,
one, tell me how.
(Laughter)
Two, I will tell you what vegan means,
because I'm sure you're dying to know.
So vegan is both a diet
completely free of animal products
and a person who follows that diet,
often used interchangeably
with "plant-based."
But plant-based
means "vegan" but not vegan.
(Laughter)
Like, not necessarily done to decrease
animal suffering per se,
but maybe to help one's health.
But that is not the argument
we came to have today.
No siree, Bob.
(Laughter)
I see some sweet-spot
minds looking to tussle.
Not at my TED Talk.
(Laughter)
Now I am an outdoor educator,
I am a wild food forager,
I am a reluctant social media star.
(Laughter)
And yes, I am a vegan.
Audience: Whoo!
Thank you.
That's not the reaction I usually get.
(Laughter)
At the age of five,
upon realizing that the cows in the fields
and the cows on my dad's grill
were the same cows ...
(Laughter)
I asked my parents
if I could go vegetarian.
To which they said,
"Sure, but let's wait
until you're done growing first."
So sure that I would change my mind
over the next five to nine years.
Well.
Shortly after my 12th birthday,
I took the plunge,
and I gave up meat completely.
It took another 12 years for me
to give up eggs and dairy.
And now between the veganism
and the foraging,
I have one of the more
eclectic pantries in the world.
(Video) Meet the Indigo Milk Cap.
Let's make a fancy dessert out of seaweed.
Here is a mimosa tree.
Please be a puffball!
(Laughter)
It was a puffball.
Now, foraging is the art/science
of identifying, collecting
and eating wild food.
So if anyone's ever convinced you
to try dandelions or wood sorrel,
congratulations, you're a forager too.
When my mom told me
that there was a bunch of free food
hanging out in lawns and sidewalks ...
(Laughter)
my mind was blown.
All these free fruits, veggies and fungi
that didn't require your water,
didn’t require your time
and often were healthier
than their counterparts
in the grocery store.
Cute little fun fact just between us,
we did this thing over the last 100 years
where we bred foods to travel easier,
be bigger, taste milder.
And that often breeds out the nutrition.
Let's take, for example,
Purslane or Verdolagas,
if you are in a Spanish-speaking
part of the Americas.
It is a weed that grows out
of sidewalk cracks in the summertime.
It is chock-full of Omega-3s,
and it ain’t a fish.
Iron, get out of here, Popeye.
(Laughter)
And vitamin C,
your immune system will thank you.
Sometimes I will just stand
in my neighborhood,
looking at the ground like.
(Laughter)
And I'm baffled that no one
else seems to care.
Now I am a forager and a vegan
for much the same reason.
My love of this planet
and its inhabitants.
But let me tell you,
between those two identifiers,
it's pretty hard to get people
to try my food.
(Laughter)
You tell someone something's vegan
and you're already met with skepticism.
Tell them it’s vegan and you pulled
half of it out of the ground ...
(Laughter)
It's a tough sell.
So today I'm going to give
all of you my tips, my tricks
on getting people to expand their palette
and try wild vegan foods consensually.
(Laughter)
This is not the Lying Liar show.
It is the Slightly Annoying
but Ultimately Lovable Tall Vegan show.
(Laughter)
So today we are going to be making
a snack that happens to be vegan,
happens to be great for the planet,
happens to use one
of my favorite ingredients.
We are making sweet and salty kelp chips,
a Korean snack known as Dasima Twigak.
Oh, thank you.
A "woo" for the pronunciation,
I was worried about it.
(Laughter)
Now I know all
of y'all's kids are obsessed
with those nori seaweed snacks,
so why not kick it up a notch --
Sorry --
(Laughter)
With a locally foraged
ingredient: bull kelp.
I foraged this right here in Vancouver.
(Applause and cheers)
Now I'm going to go
and start chipifying this seaweed.
Very official kitchen shears.
And while I'm doing that,
I'm going to give you my first tip.
When introducing a dish
to skeptical mouths,
it is best to use a dish that is not
pretending to be something else.
(Applause)
You know.
That way, they have no prior associations,
no memories to be comparing it to
of their mother's version of it.
(Laughter)
Maybe they have no opinions
about it at all.
I'm going to spritz these
with a little sunflower oil.
Ooh.
Smokey.
Now, seaweed and sea vegetables in general
are a very exciting food space.
They don't require fresh water.
They don't require fertilizer.
They don't even require land.
They're just hanging out
in the salty seas, creating ecosystems,
creating oxygen for all of us to breathe,
and creating these amino acid-rich snacks.
In this day and age,
seaweed is truly future-minded food.
They're an option I wish
more people would reach for,
as runoff, water access, labor issues
and monoculturing
plague a lot of modern agriculture
here in North America.
Yeah.
(Applause)
Also they taste real good.
Those amino acids do a lot more
than adding umami to your dishes.
Bull help on average packs
15.3 percent protein by weight.
That is for everyone who asks
where vegans get their protein from.
We're fine.
(Laughter)
Now as I said before,
this dish is nothing new.
It's a popular bar snack
in parts of Korea,
and we actually have a lot of accidentally
vegan recipes historically.
And the reason for that
is because up until recently,
we did not eat this much meat.
Which is going to lead to my second tip.
It's a little spicy, a little touchy.
Hopefully the promise of a food reveal
will get you all through it.
And it is this.
Explain to your friends that the way
that we are eating is not sustainable.
Yeah.
(Applause)
It's not.
As we are constantly reaching
for more land and more fresh water,
we have set a precedent
that our planet can not keep up with.
Tell them you are not trying
to change their entire life.
You just want them to be
a bit more thoughtful
with some of their choices,
to go for those kelp chips
instead of maybe pork rinds
from the convenience store.
I find that introducing people
to wild foods in their area
is an excellent way to foster
their connection to their food.
And it's a way that fosters
that connection over shame.
And it shares a snack
instead of an infographic
or a shocking piece of media.
Now moment of truth time.
Let's see how these guys
are doing in here.
Oh, yes, this will do nicely.
Now I'm going to be real real
with all of you
because I would never
not be real real with you.
Some people ...
OK, get out of there, babies.
(Laughter)
Some people are going to be salty.
And that's a funny thing for me
to say, because this is salt.
(Laughter)
And that's just the way it goes,
we don't get to choose the pace
at which people change,
if they choose to change at all.
But, some people -- this is sugar --
will be sweet.
They will appreciate you
for meeting them where they are.
For sharing a snack and a smile,
and maybe you extending
that bit of compassion to them
will make them make some big changes
moving forward in their life.
And who knows,
maybe next time they'll be gutsy enough
to try acorn cheese or something.
So share that snack.
And make that memory.
Thank you all so much
for coming to my talk.
Ooh.
That was a nice crunch.
Happy snacking.
Don't die.
(Cheers and applause)